oh they love me they really love me huh
i just wanna stop then stop please
how does it feel to be one of the iconic
tv dads it feels like i told a story
clearly enough that it resonates listen
michael we're not rich we're doing okay
but we're not rich daddy please
how did it come about
well i actually lived in los angeles my
whole life i grew up here in l.a and i
didn't even know white people lived
until i saw the price is right
and while they said
it's a teacher from los angeles what's
white dude doing here
but i moved from um la to west hills
and i was it was first time i'd ever
lived around anybody with black people
but what i learned was it was a
community and we all were starting out
together and i met great neighbors and i
would tell these stories to my manager
in one day he just said that's the show
the show still holds up when people
watch it it still holds up don't you
think i think so and i'm proud of it i'm
playing this new game called golf
golf what you trying to get your ghetto
pass revolt
dl wrote produced and starred in the
hugelys which was based on his
experiences living as an
african-american family in an upscale
white neighborhood the series period in
1998 and e.t was on the set
he's a lot like i think most fathers of
the 90s we grew up with seeing all these
fathers who never made mistakes but we
know that we do we know how fallible we
are in addition to that he's a he's a
young man who came from an all-black
environment and moved to all white one
and somebody turned the lights on and
now it's so bright it hurts his eyes
what do you think about when you see
that i you know i recognize it
i recognize it and i think that i still
feel that way mr d.l
do you remember when e.t came on set i
remember this didn't tell a i had to do
it
they said you had to do it you had to do
it there was no twitter and there was no
instagram and there was no tic tac it
was like you guys said what happened
yeah so they were saying if you want to
get i remember they talked about how
important that was i think that's when
they kind of thought we were going to be
a thing you ended up being yeah i did
the show aired for four seasons with
guest stars like oprah kelly rowland and
boys to men dl went on to become one of
the original kings of comedy alongside
steve harvey cedric the entertainer and
bernie mac now the 59 year old hosts his
national radio program the dl hugley
show and he's currently on tour plus
he's one of the most followed comedians
on social media oh and right now he's
working on a reboot of the huglies we
have a deal with fox and we're uh we're
working on the second script which will
be another version of who i am now you
know like with a gay daughter who's
getting married and an autistic son who
likes white women and having a radio
show that's controversial i need to have
something to say
uh and and this makes me feel
that creative
uh drive that the humans have been very
excited about the potential what would
you tell that guy back on bt today
in the very beginning this is this is
what i tell them you don't have to know
what you uh will do just know what you
want
you